So what I would like to tell you about is a generalization of both MDPs and
repeated games, that is, that goes by the
name of Stochastic games, also sometimes Markov games.
>> Mm.
>> I like the name Marcov game better, but I used Stochastic game because
that's what people call it and sometimes
it's good to use words that other people
use. And what what Stochastic games give us is a formal model. For multiagent
reinforcement learning. In fact, I like to think of this in terms of an analogy.
Which is something like MDP is to RL
as stochastic game is to multiagent RL. It's a
formal model. That let's us express the sorts of
problems that take place in this formalized problem setting.
>> Hm. That sounds very promising.
>> Cool. Alright so let me let me give
you a, I'll start off by explaining it in
terms of an example and then I'll give a
more formal definition because you know, I can't not.
So so this is a little game played between A and B. Oh, I should
have it between smooth and curly, but At
the traditionally it's played between A and B.
>> Mm, and sometimes it's good to use the words that other people use.
>> [LAUGH] I've heard that. I wouldn't say it quite
that way. So this is a three by three grid
each of the players can go north, south, east and
west. And can stay put if that's helpful. And the,
the transitions are deterministic, except for through
these, these walls here which are called semi-walls.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So these thick lines represent walls that
you can't go through, the thin, wall, lines
just represent cell boundaries, but this kind of
dashed line here is a semi-wall, and that means
If you try to go through that, say by going north from, if A goes north
from this position, then 50% probability A will
actually go to the next state, and 50% probability
A will stay where A is. So, the goal is to get to
the dollar sign. And if you get to the dollar sign you get
a hundred dollars. So if we ignore A for a second, what should
B do to minimize the number of steps necessary to get the reward.
>> Go left, and then go up and go up. Oh,
I'm sorry. Go west, and then go north and then go north.
>> Yeah, and what should A do ignoring B?
>> Go east and then go north and then north.
>> Yeah.
Unfortunately these guys live in the world together, and
what happens is, they can't occupy the same square. And as soon as
somebody reaches the dollar sign the game ends and the other
player, if the other player hasn't reached the dollar sign, gets nothing.
>> I see.
>> So now there's a little bit of contention.
>> So what happens if A and B both try to go,
to the same square at the same time?
>> Let's say that we flip a coin and one of them gets to
go, first and then the other one will bounce off of the first one.
>> But that's not a problem when it comes to reaching the money.
>> But it's not a problem, yes, right, so
the money is kind of like a money pit.
>> [LAUGH] I don't think that's what a money pit is, but okay.
>> And so they can dive in and they
both get the money, because they're in the money pit.
>> I like it.
>> So what do you do if you're A?
How do you play this game? Oh! Let's think of another thing. Is, can you think
of what, what it might mean to, to have a Nash Equilibrium in a game like this?
>> Oh, that's an interesting question. It would
mean, well, it would mean, well, what do you
mean, what would it mean? It would mean
that, neither one of them would want to deviate.
>> It would mean a pair of strategies for the two players.
Now the strategies are now multi-step
things that say, they're like policies, right?
>> So...
>> Yeah.
>> Like it's a pair of policies, such that neither would
prefer to switch. So can you think of
a pair of policies that would have that property.
>> Well, no I'm not sure. I was trying
to think about that. I was thinking that kind
of, if I were a nice guy what I would want to do is I would want us both
to try to go through the, the semi walls,
and if we both go through the semi-walls we just
go up again and then we, we hit the
dollar sign at the same time. And that's very nice.
>> So okay, good. So that,
that seems like a cooperative kind of strategy, right?
Where they're both you know, 50% oh I'm sorry,
25% of the time both will get through,
both will go to the goal together. Hooray. But...
>> 25% of the time neither one will get through and
then we're in the same place we were before, so that's okay.
>> That's right.
>> The problem is the other 50% where one
of them gets through and the other one doesn't.
>> Right, so what do, what you do if
you make it through and the other one doesn't?
>> What do I do, if I get through, and
the other one doesn't? Well if I am only going to
do this the one time then I just keep
going and get the dollar, and the other person loses.
>> Yeah, alright, so what this works out to
be, is that A is going to get to the
goal. 2 3rd's of the time, and B is going
to get to the goal 2 3rd's of the time.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So, alright, so if that's the case, if
I say, okay, A, that's what you should do, B,
that's what you should do. Then is there a
way that either A or B can switch strategies and
do better?
>> Well, if B, for example, decides to go west and then go up, what happens?
>> Yes, that's a good question. B will now make it to the
goal a 100% of the time, and A will only make it to the
goal 50% of the time. So B has an incentive to switch to
that, to this strategy if we tell them to both go through the semi-wall.
>> Right.
>> So that wasn't a Nash Equilibrium. B would wanted switch this new policy.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Is this a Nash Equilibrium?
>> No. Wait, is it? No. Because, why doesn't A just choose to go west east?
>> Well, would, would A do better on average by switching to this strategy?
>> Well let's see. no, actually. Oh, no,
no, you said half the time they go through.
>> Yeah.
>> So half the time you flip a coin. So half the time I don't make it.
>> Right.
>> But half the time I do.
>> So,
actually, it looks the same.
>> It looks the same. That's right.
>> And B would go from 1 to one half.
>> Yeah, that's true. [LAUGH] So, it, A doesn't have an incentive to
do it, but B is hoping very much that A doesn't do that.
>> Right.
>> So so, yeah. So that, so there's one Nash Equilibrium
where B takes the center. Another one where A takes the center.
I guess if, if they do, if we do this coin
flip thing, it, it works out this way. If it's the case
that if they both if we change the rules here. So
that if they collide, neither of them gets to go. Then go,
both trying to go to the center is not a Nash equilibrium
anymore, because you can do better by actually going up the semi-wall.
>> Right. And so if we, if, if collision means nobody
goes through, then, suddenly, you'd want to do the other thing.
>> Exactly.
>> Or one of you goes through the semi-wall and one goes the direct way.
>> Right.
So we can see that there's a bunch
of different Nash equilibrium here, sorry, Nash equilibria
here. And that it's not so obvious how you'd find them, but it is at least
clear that they exist and they have a
different form than what we had before, because
they're not policies instead of these otherwise simplified
just you know, choose this row of the matrix.
>> Mm-hm.
>> Cool. Alright. So let's think about how
we might learn in these kinds of environments.
>> Oh, okay, I like that already.